- We're facing very incredible
difficulties with this fire.
- Piles de gravats, odeurs
de matériaux carbonisés
et nuages de fumée.
Les secouristes qui fouillent
les débris depuis plus de
deux jours font face à un défi
de taille : un incendie
brûle sous les décombres.
Mais difficile d'en identifier
la source et, conséquemment,
de l'éteindre.
Les recherches acharnées
se poursuivent jour et nuit
à Surfside. Les autorités
demeurent confiantes de
retrouver des survivants.
L'espoir est toujours possible,
selon la mairesse du comté
de Miami-Dade, parce que
les décombres contiennent
des crevasses où l'air passe.
Mais la catastrophe
aurait-elle pu être évitée?
Un rapport d'ingénieurs
datant de 2018 révèle
que l'immeuble avait des
dommages structurels majeurs.
Il est notamment question
de fissures et d'effritements
abondants sur les colonnes
et sur les murs du garage
situé sous le bâtiment.
Pour les gens qui habitent
dans le secteur, l'effondrement
suscite des inquiétudes.
- On se disait : c'est pas
possible, ça pourrait
être mon building!
- Ça pourrait être
votre building.
- Plus ça va, plus c'est
le discours qui est en train
de ressortir.
- Les heures passent
et l'anxiété des familles
grandit, puisque des centaines
de personnes manquent
toujours à l'appel.
- Notre information actuelle,
- Chandelles, fleurs et
photos ont été placées près
du bâtiment, à la fois pour
honorer les personnes qui ont
perdu la vie dans les décombres,
mais aussi pour soutenir
ceux qui cherchent
désespérément un proche.
Ici Aimée Lemieux,
Radio-Canada, M